model Ashley Graham she's gorgeous she
spun and she does not shy away from the
spotlight in 2016
she became the first so-called plus-size
model on the cover of Sports Illustrated
Swimsuit Edition since then the 30 year
old has written a book started her own
lingerie line and became one of Time
Magazine's 100 most influential people
we spoke to her for CBS's Sunday morning
she gives great pointers on how to walk
the runway you never know when that will
come in handy she also gave us an inside
look at breaking through fashion
barriers I worked my butt off this is
not an overnight success scale I'm
talking 17 years in the industry and
blood sweat tears I've had a total you
weren't gonna make I've had agents tell
me you're not gonna be on the cover of
anything you're a catalog girl go make
money that's all you need to do and
that's all you should be doing I've had
clients tell me you're too fat and we
can't book you anymore because you don't
fit into the jeans you can see our full
interview with Ashley Graham this
weekend on Sunday morning right here on
CBS she is a firecracker guys I love
this girl I people yeah well they used
to nobody's saying that to her nobody's
saying it to her now but she did go
through it and it's a it's a cutthroat
business you know we talked to the
people from refinery29
I mean some of the things that they have
to overcome especially the Biggers of
women I mean it's it's incredible what
she's done is she makes no prop dead
gorgeous absolutely I second that thing
you can say that